if you're still playing street fighter 5  the latest update is putting a new twist  on the stages you've been fighting in  I'm Tony and this game spot news update  is a knockout since launch the bustling  Street stage has let you smash your  opponent through a noodle restaurant but  now other stages are getting these  environmental knockouts with update one  point 06 now you can get tossed around  by elephants and apprentice ally fired  out of a cannon at the Kazuki estate or  crushed by a snowman in the underground  arena just to name a few nine total  stages have been updated with the new  finishers update one point 06 also  introduces urien to the roster you can  purchase him with in-game fight money or  real world money or grab him as part of  Street Fighter 5 season pass and with  that all six DLC characters are now  fully playable to stay up to date with  whatever Street Fighter 5 introduces  next you're already in the right place